>>> WELCE"T"
M T GROWTH OF NEW
CORONAVI
HOSPITAT
OF THE UNITE STATES.
TODAY,HEHE ASSESSMENT.
P,QUOTVEN
CLOSE TO BEIVESAID.AT 4FTED STAS
ARURGES IN CASES O FOURALARMING
LAST COULD PROVE DEAD
LEER.
ERHE WINDO
TAKE A SPREAD
IS CLOSING.
ANNOUS
AS GOVERNORS AREEIRMED CORONAVUH
DEATH TOLL0THEITH LESS OF WORLDN
25% OF THE CORONAV
A ABJECT FAILURE THE TRUMP ADMN
MANY STA GO KEEP
THEIR PEOPLEN'S N HARD E'S GOVN
CALIEE45IN IN THE LAST WEE Repo
UNWANTED RECORDS.
THE POSITIVITYATE IS
AVERAGE NEWOUNT EVERY D
IS N
IN
NOR SAID
VER  LOS
ANGELES ANDIX COUNTIES.
HE H
WA LIKE
THUN OR ROLLING
BACK ON THE R
ECAUSE OTHIS, THIS,
>> E'RE NOWEAZONA ISNAU>> CNU T.
>> Reporte 1 PAUSING
ORLA. THE I ACTION AND GET
UNDER eporte STAS
STILLONDAMASKS, THAT KLE, WHEREN
UNMASKED CERER. HIS NO MASK NOW?
>>E PEOPLAKE
WHATEVER DECISION IS BEST F SAF
UR LOCAL JURISIO ROF YOU.
RONG LINESLODACOUNTS ARE SIX TF
INTATES
ALESE SIX ES, CALIZATIONS A
ALL-TIME ACROSS TEXAS HAVE CLOS
>>46% OF 20-Y IT WAS RESULT OF
BARS.
>> Reporter: INFECTIONS AMONG A
YOUNGER PROBLEM.
>> WHAT YESBARE 2F THE PEOPLE WA
INFECTED'T SYMPTO SO THE STANDA
TIFICATION, ISOLATT TRACING DOE
>> Reporter: EVEN IN YORK
CI DELNOW, B DARKEXT YEARED, TH
CONTACT TRACERS0,000
PEOP
N D RIGHT FLORIDATZOUT
FIVE, AND GEORGIA ASEW ATW. FAU
EVERYBODY WOULD WILLING TO
TAKE IT, MAKING HERD IMMUNITY.
>> UIKTHF THE REASONS WHY WO MEL
POINT, THE HASREALLY B
NEIGHBOR, WEA TO PCT
SOMEBODY
NOW WHITE
HOSAYS THE SIGNS
SUGGEST THAT THEYOECTS THE WARN?
A NICK WAT LOS
ANGELES.
TH S MG CNN
D
HE SECRE
VIRUUNOR MIGHT IT ALREADY BE TO?
>> IT DEP YOU
DEFINE TOO LATE.HIN IS ALWAYS
ANINACTIONPOT,THQUESTION, JAKE,
FEHAT THE
EARL YOU ACT, THE B
IF WE'RE THINKG ABO TF A YOU'REC
YORE HAVE BEEN WFE IT IS GOING .
GOIN TOUIREORE AGGRESSIVE
TREATMENT IN SS
AT THIS POINT, IT IS ANISTENTIA.
AT WE WILLING TO TOLERAT
IN TERMS OF PEOPLE GETTING SICK
START SOME OF THESE E. KNOWEEWE.
>> SANJAY,KIC.ON SIDE S THE MAP
INCREASEDEL
CONA. FOUR ARE D T MAP ON
RIGHT W FM AONAGGSUC OR .
>> IF YOU STAY WITH JAKE, OF L
WHERE IT
YOU HAD CERTAIN IN LOCALIZED AR
MAP, JAKE, I SEE THECOUNTRY NOW
PEOPLE D TNITED STA START TO GE
T INCRSAROUND THE COUNTRY, 102%
INCREASE IN 78%GI WAM,   THE LA
CRE'RE LIKEL STARTING TOOWTH LO
IT IS NOTBLE NOW.
THAT'S THE TOUGHSE IN
OTHERES, THE
ENTIRET OF THE
LMED, E NEEDNTAT
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT.
THOUSANDMERICANS WE  D.RERY
SA YESTEAY ON"STATE OF THE
UNION."
NT FROM TWO
MONTHS
E THER
HOITERS TECTIVE EQWE'RE EE
HAVING A VERYITTI IS IT A VER
DIFFERENT STI RIGHT NOW?
>> YOU KNOW, IN SOMEFFERENT.
I THINK HE'S OBVIOUSLY DOING
WHEHOPIN THIS, THREEREES SHORTT
DECK METH ,TEROID
MEDICATION,ENTSE SHOFFECTIVE YE.
AS FAR AS PERSONAL PROTECTIVE T
FOLLOW-UP.
LET'S LOOK AT THE PAST FIVE FIGT
WORST 30 DAYS.
WANT A 9 DAYSUPPLY,T WORST WIN
THREE, IF W CAN HE 90
DAYS.
TWO
ONE IS WHEN ARE YHAVE T
AS FOR OCTOBER
THE POSSIBLE WAVE.
AS YOU SHOW FROM MAPHEAY SECOND,
WE'REFICANT PEAK.THE IS THE W DP
S. TO VEPERS PROTECT EQUNT TORE,
SWITCHING UTA, MORECOMITALS.E'
B
SAID ABOUT THERO O
VACCINE.
>> I THAT ANY
VACCINE WILL EVER BE
EC EVE IS WHICH IS 97 TO 98
BE
GET THN'T THINK WE WILL.D SETTLA
IMMUNITY
>> DR.NTFAI,FECTIOUS DISEASE EX.
WHAT DYO THAT? IF IT IS A 70 TO.
WEL G TO HERD IMMUNITY.
CONVERSATION THRIGHT
NOW YOU VE T
THE COUNTRY POLLI THAT SAYSVACC
THEY WOULDN'T
WHH  Y